you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess comm
and I just got paired up playing against
DM Captain Obvious in a 15-10 game okay
I believe I know who this is
it's one of the tricky nights I guess we
can say
so let's see what Captain Obvious is
going to throw at me
they are typing good luck I will do the
same so we're in for a tough one here
for sure what to throw at Captain
Obvious
all right how about we try c4
so this is probably the longest time
control ive played and recorded normally
it's 15 - but I am you get a faster
pairing if it's one of the set time
controls and 1510 is one of the set ones
so let's see a grünfeld or a Kings
Indian okay
Kings Indian it is
and already I think I'm going to up for
this h3 line which rules out any Bishop
g4 move
and it also secures an eventual bishop
on III from Knight to g4 and I guess we
could go even one step further it
prepares potentially AG for advance
so that's tough
that I just stated is
a bit more down the line let's first
things first get a knight on f3
and see what kind of strike black throws
at me c 5 e 5 in both cases I'm pretty
sure I'm prepared to advance with D 5
I've also seen C 6 which is looking to
combat this trio with d5 not nearly as
common is be 5 or C 5 okay well on this
one we have e 5 so let's grab some space
and with this we have now a fixed
structure in the center I have some
space on the queenside and now in the
important moment
I've played positions before where you
know when the night comes to see five
and that's the intention right now
putting pressure on e4 I've played Queen
c2 but you can actually get instance um
trouble with some sacrifices with the
follow up move Bishop f5 and the bishop
is opposite your queen I'm not sure if
it's working exactly here but my idea to
combat this efore pawn will
I guess just be revealed shortly
I want my bishop out on g5
so that I could meet Knight c5 with
Knight 2 d2 and I want my Bishop playing
before I put my knight on D 2
okay Bishop d7 that is a pretty how to
describe
very non-committal I guess would be my
first description of that move you know
no no pawn moves just Bishop d7 huh
maybe preparing
see six and then on takes the bishop can
recapture although I don't know if I'll
ever be capturing on c6 if c6 is played
so let's see what to do here my first
thought is just Bishop to e2 pretty
natural move could also consider Bishop
d3 in on Knight c5 Bishop c2 although
there could be some conditions where I'd
be perfectly fine with giving up my
light square bishop of the two currently
he's my bad bishop these guys get in his
way so I'm looking at Bishop d3 or e2 I
think I'm still quite alright with
bringing my knight to d2 to defend efore
yeah and come to think of it another
reason why I want my Bishop bunny to
let's just put it on another reason to
have my bishop on e2 is to stop a knight
h5 idea once my knight is on D to my
Bishop will observe
an ith five move which by the way you
know black cannot yet make that move I'm
just realizing in that now I mean I
course I would see it if the knight
moved I could take the Queen but black
still needs to work just a little bit
more before this night can move and also
before the before the F pawn can
contribute and this is I this is the
direction black should be looking to go
in is playing with the f5 break so on h6
I'm prepared to come back to e3 really
just tucking my bishop away
on night c-5 if I say to myself well
black can't take twice on e4 and just
you know if I just Castle and reply to
Knight to c5 that would basically mean
I'd be content with giving up my dark
square bishop because this pin can be
broken with h6 and if I'm doing anything
but capture the night then I'll be
dropping on e4 as an example night c5
castles h6 Bishop h4 can be met with g5
throws a punch breaks a pin and then on
the next move I dropped that eforp on so
short story here is that on Knight c5 I
need to defend efore directly because
I'm not a fan of giving out my dark
square bishop
definitely the better of the two bishops
may be one of the better pieces in
general minor pieces
hello I have I have good placements for
my nights so he's in the think tank
let's see
I've seen a queen eight idea before
getting out of the pin and also
defending a piece on h5 there can be
some tactics white has against a piece
on h5 combined with this f5 move on a
capture and a recapture with the Jeep on
there can be a loose piece on h5 which
the Queen would defend
so let's see on Queenie 8 I'm a I'm a
play G 4 and just try to launch my GH
pawns this is an idea I have not
committed my King to the Kings side so
yeah I could go for this stuff G 4 H
four okay that is definitely different
hmm
I think when we look back on this one
this is a this is a move to question
that is my first impression because
normally the rook would want to stay on
the F I'll to facilitate this f5 advance
maybe there's some other idea I'm not
considering how else can this rook how
can this rooks position be justified
is there some way that the center will
open up in this 'if I've pawned becomes
mobile I don't see how that happens hmm
well I am really drawn to just playing
g4 here I wonder if I could still go
with something non-committal first oh
you know what maybe maybe I'm I'm still
trying to figure out what the idea is
behind this move I wonder if it's to
avoid a dark square bishop exchange but
I wasn't even threatening to do that
just yet so I don't know about that
being the reason behind rook to e8 at
this moment
so I'm lying up either g4 or night to d2
here but why would I go night to d2 here
I mean this isn't this is something I
would do if this had pressure on it oh
wait a second if I play g4 h6 Bishop e3
hmm maybe there is some idea with the
sacrifice here night takes and then f-5e
for this is the only way I could really
justify this move
huh okay yeah I don't know what what is
Captain Obvious have up his sleeve here
um I'm just trying to see the idea I
mean here you really spent some time on
that move so
huh I don't see how some sacrifice can
against d4 could work though like let's
just say Knight d2 now h6 Bishop e3
Knight takes e4 my bishop could actually
be trapped in a way hmm like with my
knight on D 2 and a bishop on e3 if this
F pawn gets down to F for my Bishop is
out of squares hmm okay am I just seeing
uh seeing things that aren't really
there it's probably the case what
but yeah let's see ninety-two h6 Bishop
e3
Knight takes e4 Knight one of my Knights
takes e4 f5 my knight goes to G 3 F 4
hits with the fork if my knight returns
to d2 F 4 is winning my dark square
bishop hmm okay I could also just try
and stop this h6 ID altogether by
playing Queen to d2 but I take away this
square from my night on Knight c5 I
don't have night to d2 anymore mmm maybe
out maybe I'm overthinking this now I
feel like this is what's being lined up
though in order to justify that rook
move I don't see any other point behind
it the center opens up then this is a
purposeful
I could always just castle and not go
for this g4 stuff
hmm maybe that's not bad either
just making a pretty natural-looking
move huh
yeah I guess I guess I'm going too
yeah all brother I'm torn
hmm Queen d2 95 Queen III I'm going to
go for this
shoot up a lot of time there but
yeah clean g2 it is my queen isn't going
to be overly excited to be sure if
there's pressure honey for playing Queen
III but alright
well the center is opening up I don't
really mind seeing that so much
because they are in a pin if the action
takes place here on the queenside I'm
cool without let's so let's get on with
it
just castle
I still want to maintain my pawn on d5
it is possible that I could still attack
their king by eliminating the dark
square bishop and one day having a queen
on h6 night on g5
possibly
all righty so how are they going to get
out of that pin
i takes d5 there's Knight takes e4
all right let's take I am on their night
now on a six
both of my bishops have the nights under
fire
Queen a5 Queen b6 not a stable square I
could kick her around a little bit
Bishop III they are out of the pin now
hmm well I feel like I want to give that
Queen a kick it's kind of a question her
position I don't know that I really I
don't know that this is so much of an
inconvenience anymore to have pressure
on the knight these two pieces aren't
really playing I do have to be on the
lookout for a rook sacrifice of my night
with then Knight takes e4 ideas you know
this is something to be careful about
Bishop e3 where's the Queen going from
there hmm
in a way I feel like I want to put my
rook on the open file and have my bishop
here to defend my e4 pawn and you're not
there close to doing there close to
applying Knight to c5 adding more
pressure here hmm rook e1 and then
Bishop back is another idea yeah I think
I maybe like that idea
yeah let me shoot for this maybe a bit
on the passive side but I have another
idea behind this and that is to meet
some Knight maneuver into f4 with Bishop
to f1 I don't want to give up my dark
square Bishop for this night
hmm
so on Knight c5 unprepared to play
Bishop f1 it may take more some more
work before I can kick a night off of
the f4 square let's go here
this was a possibility rook takes Knight
Knight takes e4 my queen has to defend
b1
the more work I was talking about about
kicking a knife from the f4 square is
first King H 2 and then G 3 if he was
already here because the knight and the
bishop on d7 exerts pressure on H 3 so
if I really want to kick a night out of
the f4 square sometimes King H 2 and
then G 3 is necessary
for as long as I maintain this battery
this h6 move is not there although is it
a possibility you know h6 if we exchange
bishops Queen takes b2 I may end up just
losing my knight
I wonder on h6 if I've to come back to
e3
so I take the H pawn Bishop takes Queen
takes Queen takes b2 where am I going
with my knight who would be under fire
by two pieces defending him isn't good
enough and moving him I can't move him
forward the bishop and I can't move them
backwards because then there would be a
disconnect between my rooks Queen takes
rook so on h6 I think have to play
Bishop eight Bishop to e3 I don't think
I could capture well I think I'll be
okay with playing Bishop III hmm there
you have it
h6 it is yeah Queen takes b2 is
definitely something quite annoying
however okay let's start with this and I
guess the knight is going to go here huh
yeah I guess the night's going to go
there do I have to play Bishop d3 now
sharp stuff here working working right
into a pin huh
well this could be a threat at some
point once I parry these ideas or if I
can parry these ideas against b2 and II
for one day this might be back on how
can I make that a real threat Bishop d3
for starters
I don't want to go here into this
opposite the rook well
rook b1 Knight takes e4 Knight takes e4
Knight takes e4 Bishop takes Queen
Knight takes Knight I don't think I'm
coming out ahead on that let me dropping
some stuff let's get on with Bishop d3
there's no Knight takes Bishop Queen
takes Queen takes a knight takes Bishop
I just take the Queen okay
I think I want to play Brooke to be one
yeah and now I'm prepared to back my
bishop up and then this is at least a
threat I can slowly try to remove this
Knight right around this point I don't
think black is so comfortable having the
Queen opposite my bishop so they'll
probably try to go elsewhere and there
isn't there aren't so many elsewhere
squares let's say she may have to go
back home playing to c7 is awkward at
some point maybe bring my other rook
over here I don't know that he's really
necessary or needed on e4 less than 4
for me 17 moves in not many exchanges
one pawn each off off the board
yeah interesting move quite timely was
that h6 having pressure against b2
the slow removal of this c5 Knight that
I'm referring to is b3 a 3 B 4
it must come at a snail's pace
I play a3 first a4 locks down on my a3
b2 structure and I can forget about
getting in b4 I can forget about trying
to control c5 with the pawn so if my end
objective is to challenge the knight on
c5 with the pawn it must come by way of
B 3 a3 and only then before and as you
can tell just by all the words I've had
to use there it takes some time to
actually make that happen
do I have that time doing nothing about
this pin
huh if I play b3 Queen B for that would
be so aggressive but maybe it's alright
huh tough tough tough feel like this is
something a computer would do if I
played b3 Queen b4 would be a move
stopping a3 putting pressure my night
I'm at 3
Wow feel like f5 is right around the
corner as well well I'm going to
voluntarily remove my bishop from d3 I
think yeah let me do this right now no I
don't have this move for a second I was
thinking I have night maybe I do
hmm this is a bit of a debatable mo I'm
going to try it the idea behind it is
actually a bad one
yeah I'm just realizing this now I was
prepared to meet Knight to have four
with Knight to d2 but then a knight
could hop into d3 this was a bad idea
but I could maybe try to justify it on
Knight f4 I can play this earlier
mentioned King H 2 and G 3 to kick this
night away as it stands right now this
also comes with the threat I believe I
am now back on to capture h6 Knight f4
interferes with that idea however then
king h2 threatens g3 and then once again
a capture on h6 they may have to play
King age 7 and still in this pin
for as long as this night remains in a
pin I don't have to work around this see
a truck his presence is not yet felt
until this pin is no longer
all right
you know my bishop was no longer needed
to defend efore as soon as this night
release pressure on e4
so that's him it's important to note
they could return to f6 and in a way
there may be saying draw but I wouldn't
want to go for some repetition I know I
don't know that that would actually be a
good move now Knight f6 I can move my
Bishop my rook is there to defend for
there is no Queen takes b2 in this case
so this is oh that is so weakening men
so weakening g4 that doesn't feel right
though
I feel like I there's some cases now
where I could give up my bishop for the
night in I want what I want right now is
a LightSquared bishop exchange and drop
a knight in there I don't know how I can
pull that off though I play g3 my Bishop
has to defend this point maybe maybe
King h2 first let's play King h2 let's
get a quick move in there
yeah king h2 first so that's how they
defended h6 interesting
Wow you're just going right for my
throat hear that what's happening well
it's opening up should I not have an
ensuing ag4 move right now f4 is pretty
serious
Wow they are my rook on the recapture
man holy cow eat Eakes f5 Bishop takes I
have to move my rook this Knight is
unprotected where is where is the tactic
if there is there any tactic here don't
have much time
well I'm going to take and I guess we're
going to put the rook here guess scary
wasn't expecting that move giving up
this square here okay well now I have
some squares to I up there King is more
open than my own although at the moment
I am on this opened dog and I'll Bishop
here a knight here I definitely have to
take them out that can't be right down
I'm I'm on the bishop right now there
still is this pin Knight a loose piece
on h5 I'm not so sure about the z4 move
it attacked my knight but also improved
my knight reminded me that maybe there's
a better square form I may just want to
drop in here as a pawn sacrifice
forget about pawn sacrificed I mean that
you can't even he can't be taken here
let's drop in right now still this pin I
think this is the best spot
in check now out of check I'm
threatening to take this night in one
way or the other and then maybe even
push this guy this is a strong piece
it's a really strong piece
I could try to remove them bishop d4 I
think this is the most valuable piece
the bishop right here oh yeah this seems
this seems good let's do it bishop
here's this is covered still in a pin on
Bishop takes Bishop Queen takes there's
still a pin in my queen is hitting
everything possibilities for maybe a
maid on g7 one some stage Wow what a
what a very tense middle game here easy
very easy to lose track of what in the
world is going on
right now I think I have some idea of
taking the night taking a bishop and
maybe dropping my bishop into c4 I'm
looking at blacks most forward pieces
and really trying to knock them out
right now this night on d3 that could be
quite serious of course on a recapture
by the pun it's now a passed pawn who
has the defense of the bishop that can
be something quite valuable
for black so I'll be trying to steer
clear of that Knight takes d5 is not
working to remove the support of the
night because I get to recapture and
throw a punch at the queen lacks Queen
does not have very many safe squares by
the way like b4 is the only one I don't
know how good that is they may play
Queen before who knows exactly one
minute
twenty-five moves played only a couple
ponds gone the long-term thing that I'm
seeing here that's in my favor is the
king position so I want out this King
somehow ideally I'd like to keep the
Queens on the board it may turn out that
okay
let's take with the Queen it may turn
out
that I just exchanged Queens in order to
play a little bit faster so we have that
first offer don't wing
just as I said it um I'm going to
decline
I want the Queen's on board
yeah let's keep the Queen's on board
right now maybe I can poke around at
these dark squares some h4 is an idea it
seems a very aggressive looking to drop
drop in here I maybe I might allow that
I have a knight that's anchored pretty
yeah pretty deep in blacks position
doesn't get much deeper than that I mean
this is a really good square maximum
number of moves in this in this section
black side of the board h4 how would
they defend g5 on a push or capture
Queen takes h6 must be crushing
this is still not a way to undermine the
pond even if it is at some point a way
to win upon it's always a bit tricky
night is within checking distance I
think I can go for this let's throw it
in there see how they defend these are
dark squares actually this pawn on g5
I'm just realizing now cannot be
defended I believe that this is a good
move I have pressure on g5 with also my
knight currently he's hit three times
defended once it's unlikely there is a
way for black to defend this a third
time
takes Queen takes h6 is threatening mate
could they at that point maybe capture
my night and then capture on b2 I
somehow think that's not working
four minutes fourteen black I'm glad
it's a 10-second increment writer on
this point with such a tense position
let's see
he captures
for that are you Queen takes h6
yeah I guess we're going to see mate
threat wow I did not see that clean
takes F - what a star move
Iseman Wow Queen 6f - I love it
can I still avoid the Queen exchange
hmm Queen takes Queen Knight g4 when you
try and keep the Queen's on playing very
fast
Wow
I guess rook here if that Knight moves I
have mate
my Queens defending the rook also I'm
walk now that if this nightmares I have
the bishop the knight is defending this
square Wow it's just
all together here but the pieces are
doing enough I wanted to stop Knight g3
poof Bishop b2 and then take the knight
maybe I could have gone for this right
away Bishop e2 is maybe better
yeah maybe Bishop b2 is more to the
point looking to remove the knight and
then made on g7 Wow
my queen can't go too far yeah
I don't have much time let's try this
night check can I step up
I don't think I can
I could play Knight to g4 I step up I'm
running right into Knight g4 Knight g3 I
think have to take and then play my rook
to f1
there's rook h7
whoo man now I definitely cannot take
that rook is there
Wow Bishop is pinned
oh my goodness
that is a killer move now I'm busted h3
foo I don't have a move I don't see a
move I'm down on time as well
we got pawn takes pawn as a mate
discovered check and also just Queen
takes g2 typing good game definitely
good game what a rich position
Wow there's there must have been a lot
of stuff missed in this uh in this
position right around here but Queen
takes f2 what a nice shot I totally did
not see that one coming that was smooth
I really like that it's h4 not a good
move then because of this shot on f2 it
was really nice I was played out the
rook there sweeping in to defend the
mate and then all of a sudden becoming
an attacking piece that was really nice
that was really really nice got to share
a lot because of the time control let me
go into the analysis and we'll have a
look at it with stockfish of course but
I pretty much was able to share
everything I wanted to during play yeah
I think once it once it heats up I'll
have a look at this point I spent a lot
of time with this Queen to d2 move
think it's fine see what was missed you
know there must have been some tactics
overlooked g5 is so committal hmm I
still think this is fine when I did with
King h2 and then after 94 I was really
feeling comfortable here yeah I was
feeling really comfortable with the
night dropping into Issa 'kx Bishop d4 I
wonder if there's something better than
Bishop deform
maybe some sacrifice here I could have
also considered hmm it's a bit tough to
do but I guess I could have considered
at this point a capture and then Bishop
c4 playing with this pass pawn
but I mean that is a really strong night
at the same time this is a pretty strong
night but not at not at the moment he is
pinned possibly starting with Bishop c4
Wow yeah there must be a lot of stuff
missed right around this stage it's at
such a lively position hmm it seemed
logical enough to exchange off dark
square bishop she is a pretty good piece
and then the offer of a queen exchange I
want to keep the Queen zone because I
felt like I could get at their king but
and as it turned out it was my king
under fire because of that Queen takes
f2 mmm
star move man star move maybe I have to
do something other than h4 here because
on takes if I don't have this move then
what do I have I mean I played this
Queen takes f2 if I'm taking I don't
even know I guess they have their their
options of what night to drop into g4
there goes my queen and I'm down upon
and to deal with that
yeah totally overlooked Queen takes f2
great move so with that I guess h4 is
out I would have to try something else
there is there's a there's some other
stuff I guess no I don't even know this
Bishop he has a responsibility watch
over d3 I don't want him to go too far
hmm I don't know seems like one of those
dynamically equal positions I don't know
this is a strong night hmm
once we got to this point I don't think
I have anything everything is just held
together barely but Knight h5 Wow
defending mate and ready to throw some
punches
I think after my next move I'm dead this
uh this is as it stands right now it's
just barely holding it feels like for me
here with these black pieces swarming in
and just adding one more you know just a
feather more and it's just going to
collapse under its own weight yeah I
probably maybe this is the last moment
where I could try something maybe that
something is Bishop to e2 I do not know
now I think they could I think you could
still go in for this check here mmm now
not quite trying to take out the bishop
and then follow up with the fork runs
into me so black could hold off if I
played Bishop e2 maybe this move now
that I'm taking the night but maybe at
this point there's h3 on pawn takes
Knight here's checkmate
at least my rook move prevented this
pawn advance but I think I'm think I'm
busted here I am only I'm only attacking
with two pieces and they have a couple
nights in a queen that's she can't get
too much closer than my own king from
too much closer to my king well well
let's load up stock fish and see what it
has to say about this really sharp game
out of the Kings Indian okay stock fish
let's see where we made some mistakes
let's open our eyes here to some tactics
there must be some tactics in this game
so let's get to something that's a bit
on the critical side okay yeah I wanted
to quickly question this move here Queen
d2 it's not so much a fan of going to d2
castles a3 hmm what might have been one
of the ideas behind a3 to quickly
address a knight position on c5 maybe
kill the knight altogether it's not
showing as a3 now but for a moment it
did pop up a three
now let's go with h6 and then Bishop e3
ninth c5 Knight d2 a5 b four okay yeah
you can see how this aides remove plays
a role may seem a little bit odd right
now about the idea is to kick that night
out of c5 so this is an idea a3
nd to castles and now what um yeah I
don't see myself playing Queen c1 here
rook F to be one played rook e1 hmm well
if I play rook a to be 1 and night c5
now Queen e3 yeah I got they had that
timely move in with h6 wonder if they
they gained a little bit by being able
to get that in because it's a was
tactically there because of the ensuing
Queen takes b2 will have a look at that
to just confirm that that indeed this
this capture of h6 was indeed not a good
idea so this is when it's hitting h6 so
let's just make sure I could I could get
away with this
although with Knight b5 as a follow-up
and then rook a to be one idea I could
take on h6 Queen takes b2 I could play
into b5 Bishop takes b5 there's rook a
to be one and I get this piece back ah
so this is something we both missed so
otherwise h6 wouldn't have been wouldn't
have been played
if black isn't netting a piece you know
in this case the H pawn is far more
important
losing the H pawn you know I lose the
beep on my opponent lose the H upon the
H pound is more important to black than
my be pawn is important to me
because also my queen is right there
deep in blacks position and then there's
even follow up Knight g5 ideas and I
could try to remove the night and just
put it on so something like this we
didn't calculate this out far enough
Bishop takes the rook has to move
somewhere I don't even know maybe here
something like just to highlight this
position right here it's super important
that night never move and I could try to
get in something like this take him out
and then look for me okay well neither
of us took that this calculation moment
in the capture on h6 far enough
I just saw it as a queen takes b2 and
where am I going with the night we
didn't see this follow up idea of rook
to b1 to get the piece back otherwise
you know I am dead because my knight is
hit twice I drop my rook if he goes back
he goes here this Bishop takes Knight
okay well I could have captured on h6i
drop back which is still which is still
fine in fact it says it's one of the one
of the top moves here suggesting Bishop
III but still had I calculated well
enough here III would be going for the
capture on h6 here okay and now there's
another opportunity to take okay well I
missed the idea all together so I didn't
think that was there I got a five
let's get to another interesting
position king h2 doesn't want to do a
three instead I want to shy away from
this not only for this but because of
this locking down on the structure
okay I guess many different ideas queen
d1 was being pointed out looking for a
knight move attacking looking for yeah a
knight move to attack the knight on h5
with king h2 f5 and here we go things
are heating up it's not a fan of that
move because of Knight d4 what does it
want to do instead Knight f6 get the
knight back in the ball game
although I must say I thought that maybe
still dropping into f4 was pretty good
you know and what's one of the ideas
being to I up the D 3 square there's
three pieces converging on that square
although at the moment there isn't time
to really drop in there is there I could
give him a boot and take twice on this
square because in the end I'm getting
the Queen so the end result of this
would be two minor pieces I get two
minor pieces and they get a rook you
know so I guess the timing would be off
with Knight to f4 but this this felt it
felt like it helped and the computer
says it does help it's pointing out
pretty good shift in the evaluation
right around here with E for so Knight
f6 better and then Knight a for hmm
still who knows that this this
evaluation is basically call it even
with the house sharp it is one one
little slip by either of us and could be
way downhill 94 96
there should be five kingi one maybe I
should have played h1 come to think of
it
so this tactic wasn't there with Queen
f2 five moves down the line no that's um
that's too far ahead I'm not going to
see that King G one Bishop d4 is it okay
with this idea I guess it is another
move is Bishop e2 just kind of holding
ground Bishop b5 is another move Bishop
b5 is another move hmm yeah I didn't I
didn't consider that I right around this
point I just said to myself this is a
strong Bishop let's try to remove him
Bishop e5 okay Knight C to d7 good move
offering a queen exchange Queen d2
Wow
95 and it does want to go with h4 but
not the capture on h6 after G takes h4
to play Bishop d5
yeah well I just didn't see the tactic I
know what else to say I didn't see that
shot maybe I should have sensed that
there was something as otherwise why
would why would black have allowed me to
sweep in so deep into the position here
yeah it's just a nice shot missed it
I'll definitely missed it Bishop b5 now
e3 now let's just make a human move like
this now Knight to a4 Oh okay this is
this is clever the rook stepping up
makes this hunt rook unprotected and now
there's Knight discoveries Oh a
discovered attack against the rook with
the shot at the Queen ah that's pretty
slick could I have not just played
Bishop b5 right here first the same idea
if the rook steps up and wants to go
with rook takes c3 hmm so this makes me
question something what is the what is
the difference like after here captures
Bishop b5 is fine and it's not
suggesting rook takes Knight here so
what's the difference
you follow that like at this point if
I'm playing instead of h4 capture and
then Bishop b5 it's saying Bishop b5
first can be met with now rook takes c3
and then rook takes c3 maybe something
related to the Queen being able to sweep
in timely into h6 yeah I thought that
must be what it is so let's have a look
on h4 captures Bishop b5 now let's
suppose rook takes Knight this isn't
working because now the queen is on b5
and there is no longer this tactic
against f2 in my queen enters with
authority in this case well it sure felt
good during the game to play my queen
here but that was that was rattled off
very fast they they they knew it
beforehand before i captured here they
had that one lined up
I see now
queen f2 top suggestion as we expected
but not a decisive shot Queen takes f2
king h1 still a draw
apparently Knight h5 and now this next
one as I suspected this next move is
going to be losing for me I played
rookie 3 and now it is gone yeah what
did I need to do I needed to capture on
eform hmm
Wow well I don't think I could have even
calculated much at all right around this
point but Knight takes e4 let's just
investigate it a little bit Knight takes
e4 rook takes c1 first
rook takes e1 and if Bishop takes Knight
I get this guy still look at I mean look
at the evaluation tough to crunch the
numbers in this one super sharp rook III
and it's just gone from here let's see
well that's not the top move but it
should be good enough - - and with some
time to think it's just growing visibly
- and yeah goodbye team white rook h7 is
fantastic
not a hard move to see at this point but
just the idea you know rookie seven
defend them eight all of a sudden this
rook right out of left field is uh has
some mating idea and calling for a mate
and ten
Najee 3 k h2 h3 and at this point I
resigned to main form let's see what the
finishing move is to stop it stop this
so I guess taking the night H takes g2
and here are the computer suggestions
just pitching pieces Queen h4 and we
could have had on board and discovered
checkmate h3
and then now I guess they have their
pick at this point the night could even
go into g4 for me I would have been a
nice finish but could also just promote
for a double checkmate
yeah totally missed the Queen takes F to
move that was a quite a rollercoaster
moment I guess you could say in the game
because it's right around this point
where I thought wow my queen is super
active she's hitting everything she's
right near the king mate in the one
threat and then hang on I have a queen
in your position Queen takes F to check
with Knight g4 idea that was a sharp
game that was one of the more fun
standard games I've played in a while
awesome okay well as usual feel free to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and as always I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye
you